mit Stahl machen sie ihre Geschäfte
der Gründer august Thyssen stampft ein
Imperium aus dem Boden
sein Sohn wird zu einem Steigbügelhalter
der Nationalsozialisten
als Fritz Thyssen mit dem Regime bricht
sperrt den Hitler ins
Konzentrationslager
[Musik]
doch das Unternehmen lebt weiter
die Erben adelt unermesslicher Reichtum
[Musik]
als bedeutendster Kunstsammler seiner
Zeit setzt sich Hans Heinrich
thyssenborne Mist sein ein Denkmal
der Name ist bis heute ein Mythos
[Musik]
ein Haus mit einem Kilometer
Seegrundstück die Villa favorita in
Lugano einst Residenz von Hans Heinrich
Thyssen
hier lebte eine internationale
Patchwork-Familie im TV
[Musik]
hier gab es mehr Verstecke als irgendwo
anders auf der Welt das war wunderbar
als Kind und dann diese Riesenterrasse
wo wir immer mit unserem Vater zum
Mittagessen saßen und mein Vater hat
dann immer den Schlüssel zur Galerie
gezückt und gefragt möchte jemand die
Galerie sehen es war ausgeschlossen zu
sagen nein ich habe Kopfschmerzen dann
wäre er beleidigt gewesen und hätte nie
wieder gefragt darum sagten wir ja bitte
Heini
[Musik]
wie Hans Heinrich genannt wird ist Herr
über ein gigantisches Industrie Imperium
seine Leidenschaft gehört der Kunst
übertrieben
er war süchtig nach Kunst jedes Jahr
hatte er sich am ersten Januar aufs Neue
vorgenommen keine Bilder mehr zu kaufen
spätestens am 6 oder 7 Januar hatte er
seine guten Vorsätze aber schon wieder
über Bord geworfen
Erbe besitzt die bedeutendste private
Kunstsammlung der Welt er liebt es seine
Bilder in der Villa favorita
auszustellen auch für die Öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
in fünfter Ehe heiratet Heini Thyssen
die Spanierin Carmen Servera genannt
Tita bin ich zu der Party eingeladen
die ehemalige missspanien ist
Filmschauspielerin Anfang der 80er
begegnet sie dem 22 Jahre älteren
Multimilliardär ich habe sie
kennengelernt als durchaus charmante
Frau als Frau die ihren Weg gegangen ist
und zwar mit aller Macht die ja aus
bescheidenen Verhältnissen gekommen ist
und dann irgendwie den Jackpot geklagt
hat und plötzlich hat sie gemerkt dieser
Mann ist auch schon älter und er liebt
mich und jetzt werde ich mal zeigen was
eine Harke ist nicht der Beginn einer
verhängnisvollen Affäre Kita will ran an
die Milliarden ihres Mannes dafür muss
sie einen Keil treiben zwischen Heini
Thyssen und seine Kinder
sie hat ihn aufgehetzt gegen alles und
geben das ging so weit dass wir unseren
Vater nicht mehr sehen durften es liegt
auf der Hand dass diese Frau
manipulierte was und wo sie nun konnte
1997 hat sie ihn soweit eine Thyssen
verklagt seine Kinder für die er eine
Familien Treuhand mit Sitz in Monaco
gegründet hatte es geht um das Erbe von
rund 200 Unternehmen in mehr als 20
Länder
ein Großteil des tütenvermögens war ja
in steuergünstigen Ländern nicht auf den
Caymans und weiß der Teufel wo überall
nicht und das alleine auch erstmal alles
wieder zu zählen zusammenzurechnen sind
es 7 Milliarden oder 9 Milliarden oder
doch nur 5 Milliarden
der Fall Thyssen gegen küssen
Höhepunkt eines traurigen Zerwürfnis ist
das nur eine Gewinnerin Kind
ich bin nicht wütend auf sie aber
verzeihen werde ich nie
die Urquelle des geldsprudels liegt in
Duisburg Hamborn vor 120 Jahren beginnt
hier die Geschichte des thyssenkonzerns
augustussen kauft sich heimlich die
Aktien Mehrheit an einem
Steinkohlebergwerk
unter Tage wird Kohle gefördert über
Tage baut er ein Stahl und Walzwerk das
integrierte Hüttenwerk die Idee von
august Thyssen
hatte die Zielsetzung an Massenprodukt
Stahl in gewalzter Form zu machen mit
niedrigsten Kosten und für jedermann
verfügbar er hat die Grundidee gehabt
die letzten Endes zum automobilblech
geführt hat und am Ende konnte august
auf eine riesige unternehmerische
errungenschaftlichen und seine Hütte ist
heute noch die leistungsfähigste Hütte
von ganz Europa
August Thissen schafft ein Imperium das
vom Rohstoff bis zum Fertigprodukt
reicht für Stahl und Eisen braucht er
Kohle Erz und Wasser er kauft Zechen
Herzen und Wasserwerke
für die Finanzierung seiner Unternehmen
kann er auf seine Familie zurückgreifen
oder Josef wird mit gesellschaftlicher
für den Transport seiner Produkte
betreibt er Handelsgesellschaften
Thyssen wird zu einem Synonym für
Schwerindustrie von Weltruf aus Thyssen
ist der Inbegriff eines
industriepioniers er hat die deutsche
Wirtschaftsgeschichte geprägt die
vergleichsweise die Krups oder die
Familie Siemens oder in Amerika die
Rockefellers oder Henry Ford
für viele Unternehmer ist es Zeitalter
der Industrialisierung ein goldenes
aus dessen war eine äußerst sparsamer
Mann der auch immer mit der Straßenbahn
gefahren ist und da gab es in der
Straßenbahn sogenannte zahlgrenzen und
da ist er eigentlich nicht bis nach
Hause gefahren sondern ist immer eine
Station früher ausgestiegen weil da die
Zahl Grenze war und er hätte da
vielleicht den Groschen mehr bezahlen
müssen
nur einen Luxus könnte er sich die
Skulpturen des berühmtesten Bildhauers
der Jahrhundertwende
sieben marmorplastiken kauft august
Thyssen bei August
[Musik]
eigentlich war er gar nicht ein Kunst
interessiert an den Wänden von Schloss
Landsberg hängen nur Kopien
niederländischer Maler dabei hätte er
sich ohne weiteres die originale leisten
können
Schloss Landsberg auf den Ruhrhöhen vor
Essen der Wohnsitz von augustussen
seit 1872 ist der mit Hedwig Pelzer
einer unternehmertochter verheiratet
doch glücklich werden die Eheleute trotz
ihres Wohlstandes nicht
bestand wohl von Anfang an ein gewisser
Gegensatz der sich nachher dann auch
wirklich zur Krise ausweite der zwischen
seinem Familienleben und seinen
firmenleben er war auch recht unduldsam
in mancher Hinsicht was sie sicherer
Umfeld zu seiner Frau ausgewirkt hat die
erwartet hatte dass er sich als Ehegatte
mehr um sie kümmerte
nach 13 Jahren lässt sich das Paar
scheiden die Leid tragenden sind die
Kinder der Erstgeborene Fritz
August Junior Sohn Heinrich und Tochter
Hedwig
es gab dann eigentlich im Grunde kein
Familienleben mehr der Vater war ständig
in der Firma oder auf Reisen die Kinder
wurden also von einer Erzieherin betreut
haben aber offensichtlich sehr unter dem
Hand kommen der Mutter gelitten
besonders
Fritz soll als Kronprinz die Nachfolge
im Unternehmen antreten
der Vater verlangt Höchstleistungen und
ist mit seinem Sohn stets unzufrieden
seien sie mal Kind eines Vaters wie
augustussen es ist fast nicht zu
bewältigen solche Erwartungen zu
erfüllen
dabei hat Fritz alle Voraussetzungen für
die Nachfolge erfüllt er studierte
Eisenhüttenkunde und Maschinenbau im In-
und Ausland
gewürdigt wird das vom Vater nicht
nur einmal wieder setzt sich Fritz dem
gestrengen Vater
der Grund hat einen Namen
Amelie zur Hölle
Vater August hält die Kölnerin für
unbedeutend doch für Fritz ist Amelie
die Liebe seines Lebens später erinnert
er sich
damals gab es noch tanzkarten ich
schrieb meinen Namen bei allen ihren
Tänzen ein sie war zufrieden und ich
glücklich fritz hat diese Ehe gesucht
als Hafen und er hat an ihr festgehalten
unter allen Umständen und allen
Widrigkeiten warum kann man sich leicht
erklären weil er in dieser Ehe das fand
was er zu Hause ich hatte
nach neuen Ehejahren wird ihr einziges
Kind geboren Anita
am 4 april 1926 stirbt august Thyssen
als einer der reichsten aber auch
einsamsten Männer im Alter von 83 Jahren
das Imperium geht auf seine Söhne Fritz
und Heinrich über
Fritz wird es heimische Stahlgeschäft
übertragen oder Heinrich übernimmt in
erster Linie die ausländischen Firmen
[Musik]
Heinrich heiratet die Baroness Margareta
bornemissa der ungarischen
Aristokratenfamilie mangelt es an
männlichen Nachkommen Heinrich wird von
seinem Schwiegervater adoptiert und
trägt fortan den Namen Thyssen
bornemissa
Heinrich geht in die Schweiz die Villa
favorita am Luganer See wird der Familie
sitzt einen Namen macht sich Heinrich
als Kunstkenner er investiert in eine
Sammlung mit Werken von der Renaissance
bis zur Romantik
die Wege von Fritz und Heinrich hatten
sich 1926 vollständig getrennt weil sie
völlig getrennte Teile des Thyssen
Imperiums betreuten teilweise aus
politischen Gründen anders als Fritz der
sich als deutscher Patriot verstand war
Heinrich im Grunde Kosmopolit
Frühjahr 1919 Delegationen aus aller
Welt verhandeln den Frieden von
Versailles
Thyssen ist als Berater dabei
die Reparationsleistungen die
Deutschland nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg
auferlegt werden empfindet Fritz als
Tiefe Demütigung sie werden Deutschland
wirtschaftlich und politisch in eine
schwere Krise stürzen
die Geschäfte die die Firma Thyssen im
Ersten Weltkrieg mit rüstungsprodukten
noch gemacht hatte sind weggebrochen
auch Geschäfte mit dem Ausland finden
nicht mehr statt
das Elend auf den Straßen bleibt den
Thyssens nicht verborgen
das waren schlimme Folgen und da war ja
wirklich die Not furchtbar groß und ich
kann mich noch gut erinnern dass meine
Eltern da in Mülheim eine kinderspeisung
organisiert haben damit die armen Kinder
wenigstens mal einmal oder zweimal in
der Woche ein warmes Mittagessen bekam
1923 Deutschland kann die
Reparationsleistungen nicht mehr
bedienen französische Truppen besetzen
das Ruhrgebiet sie wollen die Kohle und
Koks Produktion finden
kein industrieller traut sich das Wort
zu ergreifen es ist Fritz Thyssen der
sich stellvertretend für die montane
Industrie den Besatzern entgegenstellt
wegen
Gehorsamsverweigerung wird er vor einem
französischen Militärgericht angeklagt
die drohende Gefängnisstrafe wenden die
Ruhe arbeite im Protest für ihren Helden
ab
Fritz Rückkehr nach Duisburg gleich
einen Triumphzug
dass er in den politischen Bereich auf
einmal da eine Führungsfigur wurde was
er vermutlicherweise gar nicht erwartet
hatte und das hat ihn offensichtlich
enorm motiviert weil da endlich mal
sozusagen er anerkannt wurde
in der jungen Weimarer Republik kämpfen
linke und rechte Kräfte von Anfang an
nicht immer nur mit demokratischen
Mitteln
von den Verheißungen der aufkeimenden
ultrarechten Bewegung verspricht sich
auf Fritz Thyssen viel
Fritz Thyssen war ja sehr stark vom von
der Angst auch befallen Deutschland
könnte kommunistisch werden mit Hitler
hatte er bis dahin nicht sehr viel am
Hut gehabt da hatte ihn 1923 in München
in Anwesenheit von General Ludendorff
kennengelernt er war in mehrere Hitler
Kundgebungen gegangen war sehr angetan
von Hitlers rhetorischer und
agitatorischer Gabel
hunderttausend Goldmark stellt Fritz
Thyssen general Ludendorff 1923 zur
Verfügung der paktiert mit dem Jungen
Hitler es geht um einen Putsch
[Musik]
die Macht Übernahme in München scheitert
den Nationalsozialisten bleibt Thissen
aber verbunden nicht nur beruflich
sondern auch privat
Mülheim an der Ruhr
Privatfilme zeigen das Familienlebens
Tochter Anita lernt Autofahren
[Musik]
es ist ein sorgloses Leben das Fritz und
Amelie genießen
[Musik]
eine besondere Freundschaft verbindet
die Thyssens mit Hermann Göring einem
gern gesehenen Gast es heißt Fritz habe
Göring gar als potenziellen Ehemann für
seine Tochter Anita vorgesehen
Thyssen unterstützt den
Nationalsozialisten auch finanziell
damit der sich in gehobenen Kreisen
angemessen bewegen kann
zum einen hatte Göring auf diese Weise
Zugang zur reine westfälischen
Industrie denn er kam auf diese Weise
über Fritz dürfen auch mit anderen
Magnaten des Ruhrgebietes in Kontakt zum
zweiten war Fritz dessen bekanntermaßen
ein großzügiger Förderer
26 januar 1932 ein schicksalhafter Tag
für Fritz Thyssen Thyssen lädt Hitler
ein vor dem Düsseldorfer Industrieclub
zu sprechen 600 Wirtschaftsführer sind
anwesend
dunkler Anzug weißes Hemd kein
Parteiabzeichen Hitler weiß um die
Wirkung seines Erscheinens denn er will
Spenden die er bald bekommt nicht nur
von küssen
ein Jahr später ist der Diktator an der
Macht im Hause Thyssen ist die
nazi-regierung willkommen in ihrem Namen
will Fritz für eine gerechtere
Wirtschaftsordnung sorgen
[Musik]
Fritz Thyssen fühlte sich für sein
Eintreten für die Nazis dadurch belohnt
dass man ihm die höchste Autorität in
allen Wirtschaftsfragen zu lassen es war
eine groteske-verkennung der der
Umstände
als einer der mächtigsten industriellen
bekommt Thyssen einen Sitz im Reichstag
und wird zum Preußischen Staatsrat
ernannt doch zu melden hat er nicht viel
im Sommer 1934 zeigt das Nazi-Regime
sein wahres Gesicht es a-chef Ernst Röhm
wird verhaftet abgesetzt und umgebracht
den Mord verteidigt Hitler sogar
öffentlicher
eingesetzt in dieser Stunde war ich
verantwortlich für das schicksalation
und damit der Zeit verfallen
jetzt weiß Fritz küssen wen er da
unterstützt hat
das war für Thyssen einen fürchterliches
Erlebnis dass die Partei und der Mann
für die er sich stark gemacht hat ein
solches Verbrechen ausgeführt hatten und
später kam dann zusätzlich sein
deutliches Gespür dafür dass Hitler auf
einen Krieg zu steuern würde was ich
eben zeigte an der Aufrüstung die er ja
nun als Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender der
Vereinigten Stahlwerke hautnah
beobachten konnte
seit 1926 ist die Firma Thyssen in den
vereinigten Stahlwerken aufgegangen als
größter Anteilseigner an dem
Zusammenschluss der montanenindustrie
übernimmt Fritz den Aufsichtsratsvorsitz
mit dem laufenden Geschäft hat er kaum
etwas zu tun
was aber mit dem vielen Stahl passiert
das wissen die unternehmerfrei nicht sie
liefern die Vorprodukte für die Waffen
die das Deutsche Reich bestellt
[Musik]
die Hochzeit von Tochter Anita mit einem
ungarischen Grafen im Sommer 1936 wird
zum Politikum neben industriellen und
Aristokraten sind vor allem katholische
Würdenträger geladen und kaum ein Nazi
bei der Hochzeit von der Anita das war
1936 da waren wir als Jungens mit meiner
Mutter da und das war eine Mammut
Hochzeit im Haus in Speldorf dieses Haus
ist hier an sich schon sehr groß und da
waren dann auch riesen Zelte aufgebaut
ich weiß nicht wie viele Leute das waren
aber jedenfalls war alles davon Rang und
Namen nur keine politische Prominenz
Thyssen stänkert heißt es in Berlin mit
Protestbriefen gegen die Übergriffe der
Nazis auf katholischer Einrichtungen hat
es sich der industrielle mit dem Regime
verscherzt
persönliche Freunde von Thyssen werden
unter den Nazis zu verfolgten wie die
jüdische Bankiersfamilie hirschland ich
weiß von einem Mitglied der Familie
Russland das Fritz Thyssen im Jahre 1936
mit Simon hirschland hier im
industrieklub im Restaurant
aufgetreten ist in aller Öffentlichkeit
um eine Demonstration die natürlich
gegen die NSDAP gerichtet war zu leisten
Novemberpogrom später erinnert sich
Thyssen
als am 9 November in Falster und
brutalster Weise die Juden geplündert
und gemarkert und ihre Gotteshäuser in
ganz Deutschland zerstört wurden habe
ich wiederum Protest eingelegt alles
ohne Erfolg
jetzt bricht Thyssen endgültig mit dem
Regime als der industrielle im Sommer 39
zu einer außerordentlichen
Reichstagssitzung nach Berlin zitiert
wird ahnt er was die Stunde schlägt
er ist in Bad Gastein und telegrafiert
an Göring ich bin gegen Krieg
am Tag darauf fällt die deutsche
Wehrmacht in Polen ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als die Meldung über den Rundfunk kam
dass Deutschland Polen angegriffen habe
wusste Tissen oder ahnte Thissen dass er
bei seiner Rückkehr mit dem Schlimmsten
würde rechnen müssen nämlich mit der
Liquidierung so wie es den Leuten in der
römer-affäre widerfahren sei
Fritz flieht mit seiner Familie über die
Schweiz nach Frankreich
die Flucht des einstigen nazi-gönners
ist im Ausland eine Sensation
in Palace
industrial Chief in Germany and one of
Becker
aus dem Exil will Fritz die
Öffentlichkeit wachrütteln er schreibt
Briefe ein Göring und an Hitler mein
einziger Fehler ist es dass ich an sie
unseren Führer Adolf Hitler und an die
Bewegung die von ihnen gegründet wurde
glaubte ihre neue Politik ist Selbstmord
ihre neue Politiker Hitler treibt
Deutschland in den Abgrund
[Musik]
die Provokationen des abtrünnigen
bleiben nicht ohne Folgen Fritz und
Amelie wird die Staatsbürgerschaft aber
erkannt das Vermögen der gesamten
Familie wird beschlagnahmt und einem NS
treue-händler übergeben seine Tochter
Anita ihren Mann und Enkel Federico
lässt küssen in Sicherheit bringen das
Ziel ist Argentinien
[Musik]
Fritz und Amelie wollen Nachkommen doch
zuvor noch Abschied nehmen Küssens
85-jährige Mutter liegt im Sterben und
dann ist er im Frühjahr 1940 das muss
man sich vorstellen nach Brüssel gereist
um seine Mutter noch mal zu sehen und
nachdem er sie gesehen hat da hat sie
dann auch in Frieden die Augen
geschlossen
auf der Rückreise wird das Ehepaar vom
deutschen Einmarsch in Frankreich
überrascht
die von den Nazis eingesetzte Regierung
liefert Fritz und Amelie an die Gestapo
aus Fritz schreibt später
wir wurden in eine Irrenanstalt bei
Potsdam gebracht kaum waren wir dort
angelangt als ich zu Göring geführt
wurde der mir öffnete entweder
Volksgerichtshof und sicheres
Todesurteil oder Gnadengesuch an Hitler
im letzteren Fall würde mir man Vermögen
wiedergegeben und ich würde auf der
früheren Besetzung meines Vaters
interniert werden
[Musik]
doch das Gnadengesuch an Hitler lehnt
Fritz ab
[Musik]
1943 wird Thyssen in ein
Konzentrationslager eingewiesen eine
Großmutter amelie ist freiwillig
mitgegangen also sie liebte
guten schlechten Zeiten
[Musik]
wenn er am meisten brauchte konnte sie
nicht alleine lassen
Fritz und Amelie werden zu den
sonder-häftlingen gesperrt
sie genossen besondere Bedingungen
trugen keine Anstaltskleidung muss nicht
arbeiten kriegten zumindest in
Sachsenhausen dasselbe essen wie die SS
Wachleute aber sie lebten natürlich auf
einem Gelände auf dem sie in ihren aus
ihren Baracken jederzeit mitkriegten
dass Menschen exekutiert wurden
und das Schicksal von Fritz und Amelie
nicht alle in der Familie küssen zeigen
für die Inhaftierten Mitgefühl denn auch
sie sind von der Enteignung betroffen
ein Großmutter hatte dann darfst du
aufgerufen dass die Familie Pakete
packen sollte und das KZ schicken sollte
und mein Vater fand das als eine
ziemliche Zumutung weil ich sag erst hat
er uns diese ganzen Probleme eingebracht
und jetzt haben wir ihn auch noch
unterstützen
der Bruder von Fritz Heinrich Thyssen
bornemista lebt schon seit 1932 in der
Schweiz auch er kann oder will seinem
Bruder nicht helfen den Heinrich macht
Geschäfte mit dem Deutschen Reich ist
dann vielen Firmen beteiligt wie an der
Bremer Vulkan die für den
uneingeschränkten U-Boot-Krieg das
Material liefert
[Musik]
ganz verschiedene Personen
das Wasser
und meine Großmutter hat immer gesagt
mach nie Geschäfte mit ein
das Angebot von Nazi unterhändlernen den
Bruder gegen wertvolle Gemälde
einzutauschen schlägt Heinrich aus heißt
es später
es war möglicherweise ein tief sitzendes
Unverständnis und unverhältnis dieser
beiden so ungleichen Brüder und Heinrich
hat sich politisch nie engagiert und ihm
sind nach allem was man weiß die
politischen Eskapaden seines Bruders
immer unverständlich geblieben
im April 45 stehen amerikanische Truppen
kurz vor Dachau als die Prominenten
Häftlinge aus dem Konzentrationslager
abtransportiert werden sie sollen den
Amerikanern unter keinen Umständen in
die Hände fallen von Dachau okay die
Todes im Märsche Richtung Süden in diese
sagenhafte alten Festung die mussten in
jeder Sekunde damit rechnen dass Sie an
der nächsten Weg ist Biegung erschossen
werden durch einen glücklichen Umstand
und nur mit Unterstützung von Wehrmacht
Soldaten werden die SS bewache gezwungen
aufzugeben
am 4 mai 45 werden Fritz und Amelie von
amerikanischen Truppen befreit er war
abgemagert bis 57 Kilo er war ja in
einem Zustand wo manche das Gefühl
hatten er würde es gesundheitlich
überhaupt nicht mehr durchstehen
[Musik]
doch mit Hilfe seiner Frau schafft es
der 71-Jährige
[Musik]
sie war sein ein und alles und erhielt
sich an ihr fest ob er das durchgehalten
hätte wenn Amelie nicht beim gewesen
wäre weiß ich nicht
noch ist die Odyssee für Fritz Thyssen
nicht beendet als früher Förderer
Hitlers prüft die alliierte Justiz nun
die Schwere seiner Schuld
[Musik]
natürlich ist es ein gemessen wenn es
einen Tatverdacht gibt dann muss das
ermittelt werden das gegen Fritz küssen
ein
Entnazifizierungsverfahren in Gang
gesetzt wurde ist vollkommen logisch
drei Jahre sitzt Fritz Thyssen in der
Haft der Alliierten bis das Verfahren
gegen ihn eröffnet wird
der Beweisführung wird ein Buch zugrunde
gelegt dass der Journalist Emily Reeves
in den USA herausgegeben hatte
iPad Hitler von Fritz Thyssen
das Buch Projekt das Thyssen mit Reeves
1940 angeschoben hatte wurde ohne seine
Autorisierung fertiggestellt nun
belastet nicht nur der Titel den
Angeklagten doch Thyssen kann glaubhaft
machen dass er Hitler mit deutlich
weniger unterstützt hat als im Buch
behauptet am Ende wird er gegen einen
Sühne Betrag als minder belastet
freigesprochen
in dieser Zeit wird auch Fritz nicht im
Margit verhört als Zeugin
die Tochter von Heinrich Thyssen
bornemists sah ist die Eigentümerin von
Schloss Rechnitz an der österreichischen
ungarischen Grenze gegen Kriegsende war
das Anwesen von der SS requiriert worden
am 24 März 45 traf in Rechnitz ein
Zwangsarbeiter Transport ein 200
ungarische Juden sollten am sogenannten
Ostwall mitarbeiten einer
Verteidigungsanlage gegen die Rote Armee
am selben Abend feierten lokale Nazi
Größen und Gestapo auf Schloss Rechnitz
ein kameradschaftsfest auch Hausherrin
Margit war dabei
während dieses Abends trifft ein
Telefonanruf ein der sagt es ist ein
Transport von nicht arbeitsfähigen
Arbeitern eingetroffen und der muss laut
dem innen bekannten Befehl behandelt
werden
und der
örtliche ist aber Leiter Franz
produzieren befolgt diesen Befehl
produzieren und weitere Schergen
verlassen das Fest um die Juden zu
erschießen in ihrem verhöhe bestreitet
Margit von der exekutionkenntnis gehabt
zu haben bis heute wurde in Rechnitz und
Umgebung kein Massengrab gefunden
dass der Mord von produzin und seinen
Leuten aber begangen wurde dafür gibt es
Zeugen diese Todes
gehört habe was die da draußen
da habe ich alle Fenster die Ohren habe
ich mit zugestockt dass ich es nicht
hören muss
Margit habe von dem Massaker erst am Tag
darauf erfahren gibt sie zu Protokoll
Zitat mir wurde erzählt dass in der
Nacht ca 2 km von unserem Schloss
entfernt Juden erschossen worden sein
im Jahr 2007 erschüttert ein britischer
Autor die Öffentlichkeit mit einem
Vorwurf er macht Margit mit
verantwortlich für den Mord sie haben
mitgeschossen die deutsche Presse legt
nach die thyssen-tochter wird zur
Gastgeberin der Hölle zu einer
Blutgräfin die Juden Erschießung als
Partyspaß doch Fachleute widersprechen
das sind keine seriösen Recherchen das
Erschießen der
Opfer ist Sache uniformierter
Hoheitsträger der NSDAP der Wehrmacht
man teilt nicht das ist nirgendwo
vorgekommen dass man jetzt beliebig
Zivilisten Waffen austeilt und sagt
schießt jetzt hier die jüdischen
Zwangsarbeiter oder die KZ Leute in
nieder
welche Schuld trifft die Tochter
Heinrich Thyssen borne Mist saß wirklich
es finden letztendige Aussagen dazu wie
viel sie von dem Geschehen mitbekommen
hat aber die These das
und der Mord das als Belustigung und
Höhepunkt dieses Festes vorgesehen war
möchte ich von der Hand weisen
Konsequenzen hatte das Massaker von
Rechnitz für Margit keine ihre Nähe zu
den Mördern steht aber außer Frage wenn
man sich mit Mördern zum Abendessen
hinsetzt dann darf man sich nicht
wundern wenn man eines Tages plötzlich
neben einem rauchenden Gewehr steht
in den Nachkriegsjahren verfügen die
Alliierten eine demontagepolitik sie
wollen Deutschland end industrialisieren
auch der thyssensche Industriekomplex
soll zerlegt werden um die Sieger mit
den abgebauten Werten zu entschädigen
Fritz Thyssen bleibt weiterhin enteignet
nichts hält ihn mehr in Deutschland
da wird die Lust am Leben verloren nach
sieben Jahren
im Januar 1950 Reisen Fritz und Amelie
zu ihrer Tochter und ihren Enkeln nach
Argentinien dann kann man sie fahren und
haben uns geküsst und umarmt und so
weiter ich glaube er war glücklich die
Familie zu sehen aber ein trauriger Mann
macht den ganzen Sachen die passiert
sind
die Restitution seines Vermögens wird
Fritz Thyssen nicht mehr erleben
am 8 februar 1951 stirbte im Alter von
77 Jahren
[Musik]
Anfang der 50er Jahre erstrahlt das
thyssenwerk in neuem Glanz
[Musik]
Bundeskanzler Konrad Adenauer kommt 1955
zu Besuch nach Duisburg er hatte die
politische Hilfestellung für den
Wiederaufbau geleistet
zurück an seinen Sohn den Verstorbenen
spritzig auf Wunsch des Kanzlers rufen
die Erbinnen eine Stiftung zur Förderung
der Wissenschaft ins Leben und ein
Zehntel ihres Vermögens bringen Sie
dafür auf
hier von stiftet Frau ameliessen durch
die Polizisten vermögenverwaltung 75
Millionen und ihre Tochter Gräfin
Beteiligung 25 Millionen
die Unternehmensleitungen überlassen die
beiden Erbinnen Managern die aus der
Duisburger thyssenhütte einen Global
Player machen
die Nachfrage nach heimlichen und
Qualitätsstahl ist groß die Produktion
bei Thyssen
die wirtschaftswunderer Jahre waren für
die thyssen-manager wie eine zweite
industrielle Revolution
diese zweite industrieller Revolution
hat uns dann zum absoluten spitzen
Wohlstand verholfen dieses ist nur
möchte ich gewesen weil das ungeheure
Erbe des Fritz dessen uns hinterlassen
hat uns unglaubliche
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten gegeben hat
unglaubliche
unglaubliche Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
hat auch der Sohn von Heinrich Thyssen
bornemist sage geerbt Hans Heinrich
genannt Heini
[Gelächter]
ist bereits in dritter Ehe verheiratet
mit einem britischen Fotomodell die
Villa favorita ist das Heim der jungen
Familie
[Musik]
doch zu Frauen hat Heini einen eher
kompliziertes Verhältnis
[Musik]
mein Vater wurde von einem Kindermädchen
großgezogen das bei seinem 18 Geburtstag
entlassen wurde aber sie war nicht bloß
ein Kindermädchen sie war wie eine
zweite Mutter für ihn ein menschliches
Wesen das von einem auf den anderen Tag
in den Ruhestand geschickt wurde nach
dem Motto wir brauchen dich nicht mehr
sie hat sich daraufhin das Leben
genommen weil man sie von ihrem Sohn
weggerissen hatte
[Musik]
mein Vater hatte panische Angst davor
einsam und Arm zu sterben
das hat ihn sein Leben lang verfolgt
das macht Heini zu einem rastlosen
Geschäftsmann erst Hersteller von Pumpen
und Eier Sortiermaschinen auch
bankenbrauereien und sogar eine
ölhandelsfirma zählen zu der
milliardenschweren Unternehmensgruppe
also er hat eigentlich in allen
Bereichen sehr erfolgreich gewirkt er
hat seine Geschwister ganz ruhig und
ohne jegliches Aufhebens abgefunden er
hat die Sammlung seines Vaters
zum Teil wieder her aufgebaut dadurch
dass er seinen Geschwistern Teil der
Bilder abgekauft hat er hat
offensichtlich unternehmerisch guten
Erfolg gehabt mit ausgeprägtem
Kunstverstand baut Thissen die
väterliche Sammlung aus
[Musik]
war der bedeutendste Kunstsammler der
Welt ein Sammler dieser Größenordnung
bestimmt auch den Geschmack der Zeit
ohne Frage sein Interesse galt vor allem
den deutschen Expressionisten deren
Marktpreise hat er damit weltweit
beeinflusst definitiv
Nolde Heckel Kirchner die Nachfrage nach
deutschen Expressionisten ist vor allem
Heini Thyssen zu verdanken
bekannt wird er aber nicht nur als
Sammler großer Meister sondern auch
schöner Frauen
einmal sagte er wenn ich die Wahl hätte
zwischen einer schönen Frau und einem
Bild würde ich mich für das Bild
entscheiden das kann ich mir an die Wand
hängen und es gibt keine Widerworte
doch mit guten Vorsätzen tut sich
heimlich schwer in fünfter Ehe heiratet
der Kita die Witwe von Lex Barker es
wird stiller um den Casanova als Titer
sein Leben in die Hand nimmt
hat gesagt die liebt mich wegen meiner
selbstwellen der ist ganz egal ob ich
Milliarden habe
Einstellung von ihm die würde mich auch
lieben wenn ich helmut Müller hieße und
aus der Bäckerei von nebenan käme
1987 will der 66-Jährige sein
Vermächtnis Regeln und entscheidet sich
seine einzigartige Sammlung der
Öffentlichkeit zu stiften die wird auf
rund 2 Milliarden D-Mark geschätzt den
Zuschlag erhält Spanien das Heimatland
seiner Frau
1992 öffnet das Museum Thyssen
bornemista in Madrid eine der größten
Attraktionen in der spanischen
Hauptstadt
auch für den Fortbestand des
Firmenimperiums hat der heilig schon
früh gesorgt
1983 gründete er für seine Kinder eine
Treuhandgesellschaft mit Sitz in Monaco
die Leitung übertrug er seinem ältesten
Sohn Georg Heinrich
er dürfte keinen Zweifel daran gehabt
haben dass die die beiden
Bereiche seiner persönlichen Aktivität
der unternehmerische und der
sammlerische sich jeweils in guter
Fassung gefangen
wenige Jahre später ist Heini Thyssen
bornemista nach mehreren Schlaganfällen
von Krankheit gezeichnet
[Musik]
jetzt übernimmt Ehefrau Tita das
Regiment
die Geschäfte der familientreuhand die
der Sohn führt laufen gut aber auch
nicht immer die vereinbarten
Ausschüttungen können zeitweise nicht in
voller Höhe an den Vater ausbezahlt
werden
da holt Dieter zum Schlag aus Georg
Heinrich will uns alles wegnehmen Geld
und Firmen klagt sie in der Presse im
Januar 1997 reichen Heinis Anwälte Klage
gegen die Familien Treuhand ein
[Musik]
aus Angst die Kontrolle zu verlieren die
sie niemanden mehr in seine Nähe
auch mich nicht das brach mir das Herz
[Musik]
sie ließ meinen Vater in dem Glauben
dass er allein gelassen werde und sich
niemand von uns Kindern mehr für ihn
interessieren würde was überhaupt nicht
stimmte
fast zwei Jahre wird auf den bambio das
prozessiert für die Anwälte ist der
abstreit eine Goldgrube für die Presse
auch
und habe gesagt Heini ich kann mir das
vorstellen ihnen ist sie klagen gegen
ihren eigenen Sohn und dann fing an
hören sie auf damit hören sie auf damit
es hat mich bereits jetzt das war aber
gerade erst am Anfang dieser ganzen
Auseinandersetzung 100 Millionen Dollar
Anwaltskosten gekostet und ich gehe mal
davon aus meinen Sohn einige genauso
viel
es geht um too much money zu viel Geld
dem Richter Platz 2001 der Kragen die
Beträge die in diesem Fall verschwendet
würden sein ausgesprochen ob es zöhn
klagt er und legt sein Amt nieder das
Verfahren bleibt stecken
[Musik]
und zwar klar dass in der ewige Streit
umbringen würde darum wollten wir
unbedingt zu einer Einigung kommen unser
Vater sollte ihn Frieden sterben und
wissen dass wir am Ende doch
zusammenhalten
die Kinder geben nach
2002 kommt es zu einer
außergerichtlichen Einigung die Firma
bleibt bei Sohn Georg Heinrich der
Familiensitz und vieles mehr wird die
dazu gesprochen
[Musik]
und alle wollen es haben alle
darüber alle kämpfen darüber
auch für die Nachfahren von Fritz
Thyssen die in Argentinien Leben bleibt
das Erbe eine Bürde eine Flucht des
Goldes da kam Bücher schreiben ich habe
auch Probleme mit meiner Familie
meine Kinder sprechen mich überhaupt
nicht ab Prozesse laufen
ganze Leben lang
1995 scheiden mit den 70 die letzten
Nachfahren des Gründers aus dem
Unternehmen heute ist das Lebenswerk von
august Thyssen nach der Fusion mit Krupp
ein weltweit tätiger Technologie und
werkstoffkonzern mit über 170.000
Mitarbeitern
der letzte Enkel des Gründers Heini
Thyssen bornemista stirbt im April 2002
wenige Wochen nach dem Ende des
Familienstreits
mit dem Tod des großen Mercedes
fällt der Vorhang über das
thyssen-schauspiel
als Heini in der Gruft von Schloss
Landsberg beigesetzt wird findet er
neben seinen Ahnen die letzte Ruhe
es war der Wille von august Thyssen das
Schloss Landsberg der Familie erhalten
bleibt als Stammsitz seiner Dynastie
doch sein Erbe hat die Dynastie
zerrissen er ist im Tod sind sie wieder
vereint
[Musik]